Hellooo everybody!
Hello!
Sorry!
Sorry I was a little late there guys.
Oh my gosh, chat's dead.
Chat, why are you dead?
What did you guys do?
How did you guys die already?
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta revive chat.
Oh my gosh, okay my favorite part was just like seeing you guys be like...
The like differences where one half was like, she hates us!
And then the intro started and then there's a guy right below was just clapping.
Like, yay!
Because the intro was playing.
And you guys were like, yay!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry for starting off late there.
I actually...
I had a oh, I'll just got back from a meet-and-greet the Anime Expo meet-and-greet and funny thing about it was that um the My event manager and I thought it was at 1 p.m, because all the other stuff was at 1 p.m It was like the panel was at 1 p.m.
And then like the karaoke was at 1 p.m, and then like okay No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no it's not that I can't read!
It's not that I can't read.
Look, it was...
We...
I'm a good soldier, I follow orders.
And then later on, I woke up early and I was like, okay I'm ready for the tech rehearsal.
And then my staff was like, sorry Doki, it was actually 4.
And I was like, what?
1-1-4?
What do you mean?
It's been 1 this entire time!
1-1-4?
And so, I was like, can we do it early?
If Dragoons got there early, we could start it early.
So then we started it early.
We started the thing early, so then we actually ended it around 5.
So I was like, oh thank god.
We actually made it in time!
And like, we met everybody that won the lottery to do the meet and greet.
So obviously, thank you for the 10 get the shits.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Oh my gosh, for one of them was going to be a doctor.
One of the Dragoons is going to be a doctor.
I met a doctor Dragoon.
It's soon to be Dr. Dragoon.
She's going to raise the IQ average!
She's going to raise our IQ!
Collective IQ average, guys!
There's a Dragoon that can read!
We have a Dragoon that can read!
It's possible!
Thank the Lord!
She can read!
She's going to carry us, guys!
She's going to carry us!
Who do you think... who does she think she is?
Learning to read!
Okay, I'm going to open the window right now.
It's like... oh wait, the window is open.
Okay, that's bad!
Alright, so we do have... alright, so for those who don't know, we have an SMP now.
And so we have a Minecraft server that is basically for Dragoons.
It took a couple of... it took a couple of months to do because there was some coding stuff that they had to do.
Regarding... so this server is going to be like an ongoing server.
It's going to be an ongoing project.
So in that way, we're going to improve more and more of it.
But it's at the stage... it's at the point of stage where we can finally open it!
So I'm really excited.
There are factions.
So there's factions involved.
And so you can separate yourselves into teams.
And it is four teams.
This server is only... they'll only open to member... member goons.
Because like... it's been something I've wanted to do for a very long time.
Like longer than... I think like... I'm pretty sure some of you Dragoons remember me talking about how I really wanted to do something like this.
And I'm really happy that I can now.
This team that I've hired to make this server...
They've actually done a lot of projects for like other... other like big YouTubers.
Other big Minecraft YouTubers.
As well as like tournaments and stuff for the Minecraft community.
So like I trust them a lot to make this a long... ongoing thing.
So the server will be open forever.
I mean not forever but like you know what I mean.
But like... it's going to be online for like... like months and months.
Like already paid for everything.
So... so you can log in at any time.
There's only 250 slots though.
There's only 250 slots of active players.
So you can log in at any time.
Like even though... like but like...
There can only be 250 players on at the same time.
And so we have a whitelist as well.
In the future we are going... we're going to upgrade 250 to 300.
In the future.
And... another thing that we're going to do is that...
We are going to have a Discord server.
That's just for this Minecraft server.
So the Discord server will be synced up with your YouTube membership.
So like when... if you have a YouTube membership.
You'll automatically be able to join the server.
To like be whitelisted into the Minecraft server.
That's still like in the works at the moment.
So we're doing it very like unga bunga caveman style.
Where you just post your username.
You post your username in the community post and everything.
And then like you get whitelisted.
We're like doing it by hand.
Like the whitelist is by hand at the moment.
So yes.
We will be like updating this whitelist every month.
So like obviously like if your membership expires.
Then we're going to have to...
Because this is reserved for like members and stuff.
We don't want a way for like...
You know have like the whitelist being leaked or anything.
And stuff like that.
And there are rules to the server.
And we also have commands.
If you look at the community post.
The members community post.
We have teleportation.
We have teleport commands.
If you have...
Because you can claim land.
So to prevent griefing.
You can claim lands.
And like give permission to people.
To like do stuff on your land.
And then like...
Oh my God.
I feel like some of you guys gonna start selling land.
What?
The real estate next to Doki's house is gonna go up by so much.
There's gonna be a town that forms around whichever land I claim.
Anyway, you can claim a total of 100 chunks of land.
And you can set three different places as your home.
So you can TP to your home.
We also have resource worlds.
So you don't have to farm the main world.
All you have to do is slash teleport resource.
All you have to do is slash teleport resource and you'll be transported to the resource world.
Which will...
What's the word?
Is 100 chunks too huge?
I mean I could change it right now.
Guys, should we make it 50?
I could tell them right now to change it to 50.
I just bought more land.
Alright, I'll tell them right now.
Can we change?
Can we change it to 50 chunks?
No!
Chunks instead of 100 people are saying.
Look, we're like figuring this out as we go along.
100 is too much.
My land!
No!
Not my land!
No, keep it to 100 so I can sell the land.
Alright guys, I'm editing.
It's now at 50 chunks.
Guys, like I said, we can edit the rules as we go along.
Get my free real estate.
Alright, anyway.
So, alright.
The thing is...
The guy said that we've already made the change.
They've already made this change.
Anyway.
So, another thing is that you claim land and you teleport and set places to things.
Like you can teleport to...
And you can actually like request teleportation to other players.
But like they have to accept it basically.
They have to accept...
All the commands are in the community post.
So if you guys are like, oh what are the commands and everything.
There's also like private PMs, DMs that you can send to other players.
And also there are like you can...
Apparently if you do slash sit, you can sit down.
You will be handed three items when you start.
Those three items are related to like claiming lands.
But it just makes it easier in terms of like if you don't want to do the command system.
You don't want to do the command system.
You can use the items to command to instead of the command like the slash commands and stuff.
We also have rules.
We have rules to the server.
So obviously for the grand opening, there's no RDM.
What is RDM?
RDM is like no random killing of other members because we want to have like fun.
Everybody have fun.
So no random killing.
If you random kill, we're kicking you out.
We're kicking you out because a lot of people want to get into the 250 slots.
So like if somebody complains and they got randomly killed for no reason.
You will be kicked and then a person will take your place.
Because we have a queue system going in.
So yes, do not build any lag machines.
If we find out you build a lag machine, you're kicked.
You're kicked out of the server.
And don't make like...
giant ass farms that could lag the server.
Like it could be like medium or small size.
But no like you know those farms that you make a fucking PC.
But for the grand opening, the grand opening we're gonna be like a bit...
We're gonna be pretty strict on these rules.
Because there's gonna be a lot of dragoons.
We're gonna be able to have a lot of dragoons on at the same time.
So that's why we're gonna be a little...
We're gonna be a bit more strict going in at the moment for the stream.
Anyway guys...
I'm super excited because this is like I said a very ongoing project.
That we're planning on...
We're planning on upgrading and...
We're planning on upgrading and adding more stuff to it.
We're gonna be changing the main lobby a bit.
Because like we were expecting this to be done before my skinsuit debut.
So like there's gonna be stuff that's gonna be tweaked obviously as we go on.
At the moment, factions wise...
Um...
There's no like...
You don't get like specific benefits for joining a particular faction.
All factions are equal.
And...
But when as soon as you...
If you wanna be like a wild dragoon with no faction...
You just...
If you claim a faction, you can't unclaim a faction.
You can swap factions at any time though.
You can swap factions at any time.
Um...
But...
You can't unfaction yourself.
So...
Uh...
If you don't wanna be in a faction, you have to not press any button.
All dragoons are created equally.
So like...
I don't know.
If something happens where some dragoons believe they are the superior dragoon...
That is like not my fault.
Like...
Uh...
I literally said all dragoons are created...
No, there's no like benefit being in one faction over the other.
So...
There's literally like no benefit in being like in a specific dragoon role.
Like they're all...
You guys don't get anything special by joining one faction over the other.
It's just how you feel.
All right.
Anyway...
Uh...
So...
This is the...
This is basically the...
Uh...
The...
There's three of these.
You're all...
Oh my god.
What is this fucking Teletubbies, son?
Okay.
I love the sun.
For this.
Anyway...
Um...
So there's the egg faction.
The...
Uh...
Regular goon.
The chunky goon.
And the long goon.
There is like three of these.
So you spawn into three separate areas for this.
And...
Uh...
Because like we don't want to have too many people in like...
Um...
There at the same time.
And you guys get to claim your faction.
We do have a voice mod on the server.
But I don't have it installed.
Uh...
Because I know it's gonna get super chaotic with 250 people here.
But like if you do wanna like have voice mod on, feel free...
It has...
It's proximity.
I put the link on it in the description in the community post.
Anyway, I think we're ready.
Good luck everybody.
Uh...
We are ready.
Oh wait.
Sorry.
We are ready.
Open.
Open the gates.
07.
Oh my god.
It is open.
Oh my god!
There you are!
Halloween!
Oh my god.
Look at it.
There's so many people here.
Oh my god!
We're all... okay.
I don't know.
There are 343 players!
How's there 300?
How's there 300 people?
Oh my god!
How?
Selection mode disabled!
Disabled!
Okay, guys.
I need to figure out how to mute chat.
Let me in!
Give me a sec.
I need to message them.
How to...
How to mute the chat.
There's a lot of people talking.
Oh my god!
I'm mute!
Alright!
Okay.
We see people have already selected their factions.
Help us!
Congratulations to like the people that made it.
Oh my god!
There's so many people here!
Alright.
Option.
Top.
Oh!
I can toggle.
Okay, guys.
I'm getting... I'm being taught Minecraft right now.
Options.
Chat settings.
Oh my god!
Guys!
I'm figuring this out!
Can toggle from chat shown.
Oh!
Okay.
Commands only.
Nice.
Check, check.
Oh wait.
What the fuck?
Oh!
What the fuck has made...
Somebody has made advancements.
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm learning.
Hidden.
I did it, guys.
I did it, everybody.
Okay.
Now... Now I can talk to you guys.
Alright.
If you guys are still not whitelisted, feel free to update... reply in the comments.
In the community post.
Okay!
I need to get the admin to TP to me.
Can you...
Can you TP me to the lobby?
No.
You guys can all talk.
And you guys can listen to me.
Guys... Wow!
Alright.
After... After you pick your... After you pick your faction...
Everybody...
Head to 00 for the main lobby.
You gotta run here.
I couldn't...
After...
So, we're gonna be redecorating this into a saloon later.
To like a...
A Yeehaw town in the future.
This was made during... During like when we were trying to decide what to do during RetroDoki's time.
But this will be redecorated to Yeehaw land in the future.
So like the main area will be a saloon.
Obviously, this one's just like your house now.
It looks like a dragoon.
Um...
Um... But yes!
I'm gonna wait until like a...
Um... A horde of dragoons come in.
I'm gonna wait...
Oh, is there motion blur on?
Oh my gosh.
I have to... Guys, I had to uninstall...
Uh... I had to uninstall...
Um... Everything related to Minecraft.
Because like my thing fucked up.
Like I couldn't talk because there was like privacy settings.
So I had to uninstall everything.
Where... Where can I adjust the motion blur?
I hate motion blur.
Where... Where is it?
Where's the motion blur?
Where is it guys?
Is it in shader... Shader pack?
Uh... No.
Is it the shader pack settings?
Custom.
Advanced settings.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
There's so many...
There's too many words.
Guys, there's so many words.
Which... Which one is it?
Which one?
Post process?
Oh, there we go.
Off.
There we go.
I couldn't tell right now.
I'm just overwhelmed.
Um... Do we get priority?
Whitelist?
If super chat... No.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Brother, thank you for the aqua soup.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Alright.
That should work, right?
So there's motion blur?
No, there isn't.
Guys, it's at 0, 0.
How far are you guys?
Did I... No, there's no motion blur.
I'm pretty sure.
Did I... Did I fix it?
I can't tell.
Is there motion blur?
Did I... Apply.
I'm at 10,000?
Oh my god.
We spawned at 10k.
We're like 9,000 blocks away.
Alright.
Good luck, dragons.
Good luck.
Holy shit.
You guys spawned 10k away from us?
Okay.
That's pretty...
That's pretty funny.
We definitely... I think I wanna do like group chats.
I'm gonna ask... I'm gonna ask... Can we...
Can we do group chats for factions in the future?
And like a way to make mini group chats for people.
So like if you guys wanna like have... That's definitely something I really wanna do.
It's 0, 0.
We're at 0, 0, guys.
We're at 0, 0.
But I'm definitely... I'm asking...
I'm asking if we can have like group chats and faction chats.
And like you can do like group...
Like if you just wanna use voice chat.
You just wanna talk to people via groups.
That's something we can do as well.
Oh yeah, guys.
You can do slash...
Guys, come here.
Come to the lobby.
Guys.
Oh yeah, by the way.
What's the...
What's the thing to show my skins again?
What's that sound?
It hurts so...
What's the thing where I can show you guys my skin?
You can when you need...
F5?
Is it F5?
Okay, guys.
Look at this.
Guys, I'm a... I'm a bear farmer again.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
They're cinematic.
Guys, look.
I skinned a bear and put a hat...
Okay, wait.
Sorry.
That's...
Somebody call...
Some people call me the...
The bear hunter.
That's fucking right.
One out of 86 players are sleeping.
Good luck with that.
Oh my god.
Good luck convincing the other...
Oh, you made it!
You made it!
Wait, no.
You're...
Wait a minute.
How the fuck did you have like armor already?
How did...
The first dragon to have made it over.
Oh my...
Can you already have armor?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Bro has speedrunning.
Oh my god.
There's a...
There's a lot.
How did you get...
How did you get armor already?
Those poor dragoons are doing their trek over to like the promised land.
They're doing their...
The chosen one.
They're like...
They're like trying to head over here right now.
Oh my god.
One out of 95 players.
Okay, I'm good.
Can we...
Can we also have it so that only one person needs...
Okay, how about only a percentage of people need to sleep so that the server has...
So that they stay.
Not one.
Because I'm wondering...
I think some people would want to have it to be nighttime.
So like maybe like one third.
Like one third.
Maybe.
One third is a good amount, I think.
One third is a good amount.
We only have like one drag...
How far is it?
How far are all of you guys?
Like 10%?
Okay, 10%.
10%.
Don't worry.
See, we're like...
We're beta testing as we go along.
We're beta testing now.
Guys!
Oh my god!
We have another dragon!
And Chonkygoon and the Longgoon have made it!
And they have iron armor!
Guys.
Other dragoons.
The other dragoons are not doing so well.
The other...
You got diamond?
How?
Regular...
Guys.
We have representatives from all that...
All dragoons.
Except for the regular goon.
Like...
How does he have all the armor?
I mean...
How do you have all the armor?
Guys, where are the regular dragoons?
Like...
Where are the...
Where's the regular...
There's Chonky.
There's Long.
Oh, there he is!
There she is!
And you're naked!
Okay.
You're...
That's a regular dragoon.
Guys.
All dragoons are created equally.
I just need you guys to know that.
Every dragoon here is created equally.
But it does say something when the only dragoon representative that's here is naked.
It does...
It does say something.
Regular goons are endangered.
But yes.
We have the...
I know the phrase.
They're different.
No, no, no.
Everybody is created equally.
I'm really excited.
I'm really excited to...
Anyway.
I talked to the team and they will be working on a chat system for all the dragoons.
Because we know there's a lot of people chatting now.
So you guys have to be...
You guys have to...
Oh, Slash Resource kills you over and over?
Okay, thanks for letting me know.
I'm gonna tell that to the...
Like I said, we're live checking it as we go along.
Apparently, Slash Resource keeps killing people.
So this is like a stress test.
We're stress testing everything at the moment.
So it's live beta testing.
But I'm really glad to finally have a server with all of you guys.
I'm excited to see what you guys come up with.
And see the things you guys are gonna build.
The faction wars that's gonna go on.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's a long dragoon right there.
Yeah,
that's a long dragoon right there.
Alright, it's gonna...
It's gonna take a while for the other dragoons to get here.
So this is gonna be the opening ceremony.
We have representatives from everybody.
From all the factions.
So we have representatives from everybody.
But when you guys get here, just remember to set this place as a home area.
Because I will be making announcements here.
Whenever I stream on this server or do an event here.
This will be the main hub.
No way.
So remember to set one of your homes here.
You have three homes.
So remember to set one of them right here.
But it's a great time.
I cannot wait to see what you dragoons do.
We will have a better chat system for everybody.
To be implemented in the future.
If you guys do have future ideas that you want to give.
Regarding how the server will be run.
And what kind of quality of life features you guys want.
At the end of the stream, feel free to comment on some ideas and everything.
Any events you guys want.
Any quality of life stuff.
Any changes you want to see.
Just comment on the VOD.
Later on in the future.
After the stream ends.
You can comment on the VOD.
Anyway guys.
This area is 0-0.
So it's at exactly 0-0.
Now run free.
Run wild.
Start claiming land.
It's a free server.
Well not free.
You guys have to pay to be here.
But start claiming land.
Go.
Claim the land for your people.
Anyway.
I will claim land too.
Alright.
So I feel like people are going to start building around my town.
It's time.
Somebody feed me.
Alright.
Go forth.
I'm going to claim a little bit of land.
Alright guys.
Let's see.
So what you can do it with this tool.
Oh wait.
There's a village next to us.
Wait.
That's so ideal.
We have a village next to us.
That's so good.
Alright.
Let's see.
For those who are wondering what resource pack I use.
I use Astro.
Astro...
Astrolex.
I think that's what it's called.
What the fuck happened to that mountain?
Oh.
Okay.
There's an ocean here.
I don't want to claim there.
Uh.
No.
Somebody has to feed me later guys.
Alright.
I am the mayor.
I'm the mayor of the server.
No.
I'm the president of the server.
Sorry.
I'm in shader pack.
Um.
I am the president of the server guys.
Oh!
Oh wait.
No!
Presidents get reelected.
No.
I'm not corrupt president.
I'm...
Guys.
I am the...
I am the queen.
I am the queen of the server.
So that means like I'm in power forever.
You can't reelect the queen.
You can't re-elect the queen.
No.
I'm not a dictator.
I'm a good person.
Where are you gonna claim, fellow dragoon?
Where are you gonna claim, long goon?
Where the fuck?
Where do I wanna live?
I don't know where to live.
There's like so many...
Oh.
Toxic...
Wait, is this your land?
That's so funny!
It's like, welcome to my land.
Oh my god!
Wait, that's so good!
I love that!
It like shows...
You're in Toxic's world now.
That's so good!
Oh, feel the wild.
Oh no, it's the PvP zone!
Not the PvP zone!
No, it's the wild!
Has music been playing this entire time?
Oh nice, okay, that's good.
Alright.
I'm gonna go play this.
Back to the... I love the fucking...
Oh no.
I love the... like...
You know what would suck?
If like, right underneath...
Wait, I want this to be my town.
Oh, this is gonna be my area.
Okay.
Is this how I claim it?
I don't know if I'm claiming it.
Am I claiming it?
Am I doing it?
I think I'm doing it.
Doki Birdo of Doki Birdo.
This is mine now.
I know!
Yeah, this is my land!
I did it guys!
Welcome to my tiny land.
Welcome.
Wait, I can rename it!
There were so many commands.
Okay.
Home.
Set.
Tap to...
Okay, let's see.
TP.
Land claim.
Trust.
Oh, land rename!
Okay, I can rename my area.
Alright, watch this.
I'm gonna rename my area now.
Um...
Oh shit, I disabled the chat.
Whoops.
Uh...
Oh, I got it!
Uh, chat settings.
Uh...
Alright.
Okay.
Slash.
Land rename.
Um...
Uh... shit.
What do I name it?
Doki Land.
Is this it?
Am I... is it Doki Land now?
Is it Doki Land?
Is it...
Is it... Doki...
No!
How do I rename my land?
Land...
Re... Oh!
Land rename.
Okay.
Doki Land.
There we go.
Yay!
Does it work?
Wilderness.
Is Doki Land working?
Doki Land!
Oh my god!
I did it!
I got Doki Land!
Okay, let's like...
Get the fucking text smaller.
Alright.
Let's see...
Maybe like...
Off.
Did that work?
Okay.
It's okay.
You guys saw the...
The SMP cause it's like...
No!
I accidentally disconnected.
Oh my god!
Doki Land!
I'm back!
I'm back in Doki Land!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Hello!
I requ...
Oh my god!
Okay, by the way.
Here's the tomatoes.
We have tomatoes, by the way.
Okay, I need more food.
Guys, I need to be fed.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I have priority queue.
So, like, I get to be here.
I have...
I have priority queue.
So everything's fine.
Alright, so this is my land, guys.
It's...
It's the land.
You guys like it?
It's my land.
You guys can build a town around me.
One out of twenty-one.
Good luck.
None of us have beds.
Oh my god!
Two people!
Two people are sleeping!
Guys!
I don't have a torch, guys.
Wait, I need to get tools too.
Guys, give me a sec.
Five.
Oh my god!
More people!
You guys have beds?
Like, what?
How do you guys have beds already?
How do you guys do that?
Okay.
I need to make, like, a crafting table.
There's, like... I need so many things.
Oh my god!
We worked together!
We did the first task.
We worked together.
And, like, created.
Like, and got... and went to bed.
We fucking did it, guys.
Alright, six.
And I wanna make a sign.
Okay.
Alright.
Welcome...
to... Doki Land.
There we go.
This is... this is the capital city.
This is...
This is the capital city, guys.
Doki Land.
Is the capital city.
And thus a town shall form around me.
Yes, it's still mine!
I claimed it!
I... You know it's mine!
Cause the moment I leave, it's the wilderness.
But then, I...
Leave here and then it's civilization.
It's civil...
Everything the light touches is mine.
It's...
Look, Rome started out as small.
Okay, guys?
Rome was a very small city.
Okay?
And then it got bigger and bigger.
And then...
I have a bed!
This is pure civilization.
I literally have a bed.
I need food now.
Okay.
The city of...
Oh no, I'm in the wild now.
I'm in the fucking wild.
Rome didn't manifest out of nowhere.
Chat.
Like, it took years to build Rome.
Guys.
It took years.
Doki Land is gonna expand.
Okay?
This... We're improving on Rome.
We're gonna be better than Rome.
We're gonna be so much better than Rome.
I need to kill a pig.
Cause I'm fucking starving.
Okay, wait.
Oh shit.
I need to go back to Doki Land.
My crafting here is here.
Doki Land wasn't built in a day, guys.
Alright?
We're at 1% of Doki Land.
We're merely 1%.
If you build... Guys.
If you build around Doki Land, you gotta pay taxes.
Yeah.
Good idea.
You know what?
Whoever said that...
Alright.
Chest.
Okay.
Which is outside of Doki Land.
Alright.
There we go.
Now you should be able to like...
Uh...
Tax Doki Land taxes.
Alright.
I need to build another.
I need to...
I need to build...
Okay.
Let's see.
Boom.
Alright.
Good thinking.
Whoever had the idea, you were so smart.
Alright.
Guys.
If you...
If you build around Doki Land, you gotta pay the Doki Land taxes.
You have to pay the Doki Land taxes.
I...
Yes.
Are you here to feed me?
Feed me.
Wait.
I don't have a... I don't have a fucking furnace.
Like...
You think I have rocks?
You think I have coal?
Feed me coal.
What do you mean?
I don't have coal.
I don't...
Alright.
Okay.
I needed... I was gonna make materials.
I was gonna make tools.
I wasn't gonna...
I wasn't gonna leech.
Guys.
I know how to Minecraft.
Uh...
I'm not gonna eat raw meat.
My god.
Cesar wouldn't have to eat raw meat.
Whoa.
Nice.
I found diamonds, guys.
Uh... Here's my Doki Land taxes.
Oh, god.
Oh, my god.
The taxes almost killed me.
Greed almost got me.
Um... Maxwell, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Berries.
Oh, my god.
I can put berries...
I can put berries around.
Hello, guys.
Are you here to pay tribute to Doki Land?
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna put this around the taxes.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I wanted.
I only wanted to eat.
I don't want it to eat.
Alright.
Nice.
How the fuck did you guys find all of this stuff?
Okay.
I hope someone builds like a coliseum.
Oh, my god!
Guys, I found diamonds!
Okay.
I think I need...
Not again.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna need some fucking... I need some fucking... Oh, my god.
I'm being fed.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, guys.
Remember to put your taxes here.
If you guys want to give me anything because you're getting taxed.
Uh...
Let's see.
I need to build a furnace.
Furnace time.
Furnace.
I can't wait to see what you guys build, though.
Uh...
And then I need...
Oh, my gosh.
I still need to...
Alright.
Boom.
It's time to find... Has anyone donated coal yet?
No.
They've only given me... What am I gonna do with bread?
You think I'm a bread leader?
Guys!
I am a queen!
You think queens live off bread?
Oh, my god.
Coal.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab...
Uh...
Bread is for peasants!
Damn right!
You're gonna give me bread?
Alright.
Let's...
Uh...
Bread.
Yeah.
Bread is actually really bad for broods.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's see.
Doki Land.
Uh... Oh, I have coal now.
So... We are finally...
Oh, my god.
What's in my...
Did people see... Okay.
Oh, I have lily pads.
Oh, my god!
People... I fucking have...
Fucking coal!
Let's go.
That's right!
I've got a mud in there.
For the queen.
Oh, no.
I'm in the wild.
For the queen of the server.
I'm actually really interested in seeing what you guys do, though.
Uh... My bread tastes so good.
Bread is poisonous!
To birds!
What does that say about you guys?
You guys wanna poison me?
Look at this humble home.
I'm gonna visit the peasants.
Hello, peasant.
Here you go.
You deserve a bread.
Oh, my god.
Wait.
I have to go.
I should, like, give bread to my...
loyal subjects.
I'm bad at bread.
Bread is too good... too bad for me.
I should go feed...
the poor peasants that live around Dokiland.
That should be what I want.
That should be what I do.
You know what?
That's a good...
What the fuck?!
Oh, my god.
Remember to pay your taxes, Ozzy.
Remember to pay those taxes.
Alright.
There's, like, a lot of bread.
Okay.
I'm ready to...
I'm gonna feed the poor.
I'm gonna...
Don't worry!
My humble subjects!
I'm here to feed you guys!
Oh, no.
The wilderness.
Bread is bad in Dokiland.
But, like, um...
I'm here...
to, like, welcome...
Hello!
You poor... dragon!
Do not worry, dragon!
Here!
Have some...
Have some bread!
There you go!
You're welcome!
Remember what the queen did for you.
Oh, shit.
I need a...
I need a fucking... I forgot I need to sit at home.
Um...
I need to sit at my home.
Guys, I need to, like, be able to teleport back to my house.
Uh...
Yeah, but it's raw meat!
I have cooked food.
I'm... I'm such a good queen.
I'm...
Alright.
Let's see.
I need to make sure I set my house.
Oh!
I built that too!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let me...
Set... home...
Okay, how do I do this?
I need to look at my command.
Set home Doki Land.
Alright, there you go.
Uh...
Set home Doki Land.
There you go!
That should have worked.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I'm gonna make sure it works.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Uh... T-P... Oh!
Home... Home...
Home Doki Land.
I did it!
Guys...
I have the magic power.
Alright, let's explore...
around me.
Uh...
Longoon Land.
Why is there...
Longoon Land?
Oh my god.
Alright, feel the wild.
Oh my gosh, the dragons are working together and sleeping again.
Go dragon, go!
Make it day!
There you go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so glad to be able to meet you at Anime Expo.
I'm so glad you love my Doki doll.
I hope to see you next year.
Thank you for all the laughter.
By the way, here is my tax payment.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you had a great time at Anime Expo.
It was great to meet you.
Yeah, but where are the other...
Where are the other goons?
That set up base.
Where are they all living?
I have Longoon Land.
One of many.
Where do the other dragons live?
Is there anybody living next to the village?
I can't believe we have a village right next to us.
That's so convenient.
It's actually 7k blocks away.
It's like the trek to Doki Land.
It's like an actual adventure.
The head chair.
It's like the trek to Doki Land.
The secret land of Doki.
Making 10k blocks away.
What the fuck?
Is this supposed to be here?
Who built this?
Wait, who lives there?
Who lives here?
Who the fuck James A.
claimed?
You claimed the village?
Oh, that's evil.
Bro, he claimed an entire village.
That's so evil.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
He actually claimed it.
Who made this?
This is a dock.
What's going on here?
Oh my god.
What are you making?
Chonky-kun!
Don't worry!
I am here as your humble queen.
I am here to feed the poor.
Here you go.
You deserve it.
Go at it, soldier!
Kala is in the name of Doki Land.
Look at Migo.
I'm such a good queen.
I'm making sure...
everybody has...
Everybody has the food they need.
To live.
Can you there?
Can you there, Cypher?
Here you go!
You deserve it!
My poor... so poor...
peasants that live around me in Minecraft world.
Cypher...
Oh shit, I pressed R.
I actually refreshed my...
resources back.
Oh my god.
Now I'm back in the wild.
Wait, who lives here?
Who lives here?
What is this place?
Oh my god.
Nobody claimed this?
Is this your home!?
U blab la.
This was your home.
Oh my God...
This is now Doki Land 2.
Welcome to Doki Land 2!
Doki Land 2, the sequel.
No!
Shit, okay.
Doki Land 2.
It's our home now.
Welcome!
Let me rename this.
Land...
Home...
Shit, how do I rename again?
Land... rename.
Okay, Land...
Rename...
Doki Land 2.
Wait, does this like...
Oh my god, there's a tomato?
Wait.
Feel the wild.
Does it say Doki Land still?
Does it say Doki Land?
Guys, I'm testing out my land real quick, guys.
I'm testing out my land.
Guys, give me a sec.
Why is my land not showing up?
No.
I claimed this land fair and square.
I claimed it fair and square.
Where's my land?
Alright, let's see.
Why is my land not showing up?
I claimed it!
I did!
It was my land!
Oh no.
Did I not claim it?
Did it got unclaimed?
Did my land got unclaimed?
Give me a sec.
Okay.
There we go.
Slash claim.
Is mine now?
Doki Land!
There we go!
Guys, I did it.
Welcome to Doki Land.
This is also Doki Land now.
Guys, this is...
This is Doki Land 2.
They worked so hard to build it.
But it's now mine.
It's now mine.
Eggtown.
Oh my gosh.
There's Eggtown.
I got the Doki docks.
Yeah, I need the docks, guys.
Whoever controls the water controls the kingdom.
You guys have to know that.
If you control the water, you control the kingdom.
I need to be sure that they know.
That they know.
Holy shit.
How much would property...
Oh wait.
I should like make a sign to be like...
Um...
Welcome...
Uh...
Somebody make a dock next to my land.
I need somebody to make a ship dock next to it.
Of course there's taxes.
The world is filled with taxes.
You think I wouldn't tax my people?
I'm a queen.
I'm the queen.
Of course I tax people.
Alright.
If you come here...
Follow the flow.
From the ocean.
I need you guys.
Okay.
I need a crafting table.
Give me a sec.
Let me make a crafting table.
And then I need a chest real quick.
Okay.
Chest.
Uh, oh shit.
Okay.
Give me a second.
I need to fucking find some trees.
I need to find some trees.
Guys, look.
Being a queen is very, very hard work.
I need to make sure I have a chest.
Whose place is this?
Thank you.
Oh yeah, I can do this because I'm the owner.
I can actually...
Other
people's builds because I'm the owner.
Yeah,
you thought this was yours.
That's messed up.
Welcome to Doki Land.
I can't creep other people's lands just because I'm the server owner.
It's great.
I love being the queen.
If you... what the fuck?
Alright, build me a dock.
This is where the taxes will go.
Alright, let's see.
I need a sign.
Sign.
That's so funny.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Fuck, okay.
I need more wood.
Alright.
I'm the HOA.
That's all I need to hear.
What?
You don't trust me?
He doesn't need this tree!
He's already rich!
He has entire town!
He doesn't need this tree.
This one tree.
The HOA is back.
He doesn't need it!
Like, the queen needs it more.
The queen needs this more.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh... free the dragon from the taxation.
No.
No, you don't get to say that.
Alright, don't worry.
Okay.
Tax time.
Uh...
Uh... how do I do this?
Taxes.
Alright, there we go.
I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure all my dragoons live off well.
Alright, let's explore more.
It's fun seeing what you guys are up to.
Uh...
I gotta feed...
I gotta feed the peasants around my kingdom, guys.
Guys, I gotta make sure the peasants that live around my kingdom are having a good time.
Hello, fellow peasants!
Hello!
I am here to grant you...
Get out of the crafting.
Listen to me!
I am your queen!
And I am here to give you gifts.
Eat!
My present.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Somebody's planting bamboo!
Nice.
My bamboo.
Wait, who's building a fucking tower?
Oh!
Oh my...
Woo!
Okay.
Alright.
Um, that scared the shit out of me.
Wait, who lives here?
Did no one claim this land?
Who lives here?
Who...
Who lives in...
Wait, who lives here?
This is not claimed officially.
Oh!
The...
Okay.
We're gonna leave.
Take me back to the wild.
Germany?
What?
Who's building a country?
What the fuck is Germany doing here?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, my people!
My people!
Kill him!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I shall feed my peasants.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, peasants.
I shall make it rain.
Woo!
Oh my gosh!
I'm such a good person.
I'm such a good queen.
I think.
Oh wait, someone got an alloy!
An alloy?
Somebody got an alloy already!
It's gone.
Oh my god.
Look at me go, feeding my hungry peasants.
Down with the queen.
Oh my god.
I'm glad people are enjoying it.
Oh my gosh, there's a chicken!
There's a chicken here!
There was...
There was a chicken.
I heard it.
I heard it die.
There was... Oh!
Faction?
Are you a hermit?
You're living so far!
Hello, your queen is here to welcome you to Doki Land.
Eat!
Oh my god, this guy is a hermit.
It's so cool to explore with everybody.
Oh, there's a black sheep here too.
Do they claim the jungle?
Yeah, they live in the jungle.
Those wild peasants.
Barbarian...
Look, they might be a barbarian dragoon, but they're still a dragoon in the end.
I wonder if anybody has claimed land from all the way there.
Oh!
I hear like some of you guys are really far.
I'm gonna... Okay, I'm gonna ask the admin.
I'm gonna... Wait, okay.
Okay.
Admin.
Admin!
Can you TP me to the far...
far...
claim?
What's the dragon faction area?
Faction area.
I want to see the dragoons from afar.
I want to see the dragoons that have conquered the land from way far...
What the fuck?
Who claimed this one tiny area?
What land did you claim?
What the fuck kind of land did you claim?
What did you...
What is this house that you have?
The fargoons.
I want to see the fargoons.
Oh my god.
The fargoons!
Alright, it's time to TP.
What was it?
I keep always having to remember...
Home...
Doki Land.
I'm back home.
I'm back in the Doki Lands.
Oh my god, look I got a flower.
Let's see.
Let's put this banner here so you know...
Okay.
You know we're good people.
Uhhh... yeah.
The smaller spawns.
The dragoons...
that spawned...
10k blocks away...
from the lobby!
Wait, I want to add...
a note here too.
Okay,
give me a sec.
I just had a note.
Uhhh...
Server is only...
open to member...
dragoons.
Join the members!
To join the...
Doki Dragoon SMP!
Hahaha!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh shit, let me make sure it's like...
Boop!
Alright, so people know.
People will be like...
Well, how do we join?
Now you know.
It's really tiny, but now you know.
Hahaha!
Become... WHOA!
The
queen is here!
Hello!
Chonkygoon!
The queen is here!
To say welcome!
The dragoons from the land of far!
Hahaha!
The dragoons from the far!
Your queen is here!
To welcome you all!
Hahaha!
The fargoons!
You know...
You guys, you guys are alright.
You know, you guys are like...
I'm like in England right now, and you guys are like...
in America.
You know?
Like...
Hahaha!
But you guys won't rebel!
You guys won't rebel!
Like America!
You guys are from across the ocean!
Did you guys claim any land?
Oh my god!
They look like...
The Austrians!
Yeah!
These guys are like...
The Americans!
Whoa!
Oh, guys!
What's going on?
Hahaha!
The queen lives!
Everybody!
Sit around me, guys!
I'm not doing okay!
So please sit around me!
Sit, guys!
Sit!
Slash sit, guys!
I need you guys to all slash sit!
The queen is here!
I traveled all across the ocean!
Slash sit for me!
Slash sit!
Yes!
Sit down!
Everybody!
The queen wants to talk!
Sit down!
Slash sit!
Guys!
Hahaha!
We're back!
Guys, we're back again!
Nothing...
I don't know what happened.
My internet was being fucking crazy just then.
Um...
Uh...
Anyway...
Hahaha!
Alright!
Everybody!
It was... It's great to see the dragoons from afar!
Guys!
I need...
Take me to your land!
Where did you guys set base?
Also, the queen grants you food!
I am a nice queen!
I am a good queen!
Anyway, guys...
I need to know...
I need to know, guys.
Show me your land!
I wanna know what you guys built!
Uh... I need to know!
What have you guys built?
What have you guys... Show me where you've claimed your land!
What have you built, guys?
Show...
There is no more embossing say.
Thank you for the aca sopa, Maxwell!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, I'm gonna follow one person.
Have you built something?
Do you have something for me to show?
No?
Are you just following me?
Okay... Oh!
This guy!
This guy has something to show!
Do you have something to show?
You do?
Alright.
What do you have?
You don't?
Are you guys all homeless?
You guys had so much time to build some...
America!
What are you guys doing, America?
I left you guys alone!
And you have nothing to show me?
Your queen is not happy.
I can't believe it!
I can't believe you guys are homeless!
I am disappointed.
The queen is not happy.
You guys had so much time and you built nothing?
You guys built nothing?
There's so much land around you!
Like...
What do you mean you guys built nothing?
What do you mean?
I can't believe it.
Where's your base?
You didn't even claim any land!
Drug American goons!
You didn't even...
Germany has land!
Fucking...
Fucking Germany had land!
Where's your land?
I provided you guys a home.
We need public housing.
That's too much to ask for.
Alright, your queen is a little disappointed.
I'm in a relationship.
I'm a little disappointed in you guys.
Guys, the Dragoons from Dokiland have already built so much.
America, I left you guys alone for like an hour!
for like an hour!
And there's no mega house yet?
I don't understand.
That's the old word.
Not even a dirt house!
There's no land claim anywhere!
There's no...
I'm just saying.
The goons back in Dokiland...
The goons back in Dokiland, they've already built so... they've already claimed everything around Dokiland.
But like, oh my god.
I said you guys away to the new world.
I said you guys away to the new world!
And you guys didn't have anything to show for me?
How would you pay for the taxes?
How would you pay for the taxes in the new world?
Alright, I'm going back.
Goodbye American Dragoons.
Goodbye new world Dragoons!
You've disappointed your queen!
Goodbye!
I forgot the commands for this again.
There we go.
Back to Dokiland we go.
Hello.
Have you guys given your taxes back?
Look at these civilized goons that have built stuff around Dokiland!
Look at that!
This goon has a house foundation already set up!
I see big houses in front of me!
The new world goons knows what's up.
I mean sorry the old world goons knows what's up.
No taxes without representation.
Thank you Miracle for the super chat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is the old world Dragoons know what to do.
Look!
This is the This guy has a home!
It's a shitty home!
But it's a home alright!
Like...
Like look at these guys!
They know what they're doing!
It's not stealing!
It's taxes!
It's just taxes!
It's really nice to pay a visit.
Umm...
Umm... Just stole Lithuania's iron?
Yeah, tell that to the British.
The queen requires...
Oh wait!
Is that a bird?
Oh my god!
Is that your bird?
Oh it's your bird!
Oh that's so cute!
Oh you can't make it dance yet though.
It's different.
It's different!
Alright, I wanna see if anyone Alright, I wanna see if anyone already built a dock yet.
Umm... It's fun!
I'm so glad you guys can play on the server with me.
I can't wait to do more... What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
Port eggs.
Ha ha ha!
Eggtown and port eggs.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god!
That's my dock!
Coyote.
I like how people have already built...
Doki Land 2!
Where I stole from Miku.
Ha ha ha!
What is this?
The Chonky Goons have something else to say about that.
Uh...
Long Goons have claimed this dock.
Wait, what?
Ha ha!
This is a dock for everybody!
Oh, are you guys actually making a ship dock?
What is this?
Portatep made...
Ha ha ha!
Portatep made a dock!
Oh my god!
That's funny!
What does this say?
What the fuck is that?
I can't... They're trying to make a word.
I don't even know what word they're trying...
Oh, dock!
Ha ha ha!
Is that... What's that word?
D... O...
Uh...
Ha ha ha!
Oh, is it Doki?
Oh, it's Doki!
Oh!
That's so cool!
Somebody...
Poor guy who was trying to make a dock and it got claimed.
Doki can't read.
You guys already know that I can't read!
Like, it's not new at all!
Sorry, I'm not actually playing Minecraft.
I'm just exploring.
It's fun!
It's fun seeing what you guys are doing right now.
Is it... Ha ha ha!
I am James of the Iris.
I own a village now known as Legoland, which is at spawn.
You owe me one diamond for that one!
Take it illegally!
Who said that?
James?
This is your town?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
This is your town?
Don't make me kill this villager right now, James.
Nobody governs!
Queen Doki!
Ha ha ha ha!
Do you...
I can make...
I can make a... I can get flint right now.
Ha ha ha ha!
I can... I can get flint right now and there will be no village.
You won't want that, James!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
Wait, somebody's already kidnapping your villager!
Ha ha ha!
James, your villager's getting kidnapped!
Oh my god!
They're kidnapping your villager!
They're... Ha ha ha!
James!
You kidnapped your villager, James!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
James, you're not doing so well!
I like...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
You already took your villager away!
What is this guy trying to write?
What is this... Ha ha ha!
What is this guy?
It's called...
Oh my god!
He's rowing away!
Very slowly.
Ha ha ha!
They're gonna escape in three or four business days!
Hurry, James!
Oh hey, look, everybody's here!
Welcome to the lobby!
Welcome, everybody!
Are you guys having a good time?
Welcome!
This is the lobby area.
We're gonna upgrade this more later on.
Ha ha ha!
It's an arranged marriage.
We watched the kidnapping live on stream.
Oh my gosh.
It's been pretty fun so far.
Ooh!
Should we kill the ender dragon right now?
Guys, let's do it.
Should we do it?
It'd be so fun.
We all just like went to the ender...
Enderworld and then killed it in like...
I'm pretty sure somebody has already killed the ender dragon.
Like...
Oh my god!
Is this all your land?
That's fucking insane.
That's a lot of land.
The last time, like, the...
The Minecraft dragoons that broke into the server because our whitelist fucked up.
They like...
They killed the ender dragon in like two hours.
So I won't be surprised if they're almost there.
Alright!
Let's go kill the... We need public housing projects for the new world.
One of you guys better build it.
You think I'm gonna build it?
Like...
You think... You think I'm gonna build public housing?
That's...
Oh my god!
There's your chickens!
What if they follow me?
What about me?
I'm not a bad person.
It's okay.
Go lead your chicken over here.
Mine now.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, I have more food.
I have more food.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Whoever wants to beat the ender dragon, go to the lobby.
For those who are 10,000 blocks away, I'm sorry new world goons, but like, we'll meet you in the ender world.
Uh...
Go to the...
The new world goons will meet you in the ender...
The ender world.
For now.
Everybody at the old world.
The old world.
Come to the lobby.
Even know where the portal is?
Somebody has to know where the portal is.
Um...
Alright, guys.
Everybody!
Go to the lobby.
Alright, let's wait until they sleep.
When they sleep.
Alright, guys.
You guys ready?
You guys ready to kill the ender dragon?
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Alright, who knows where the ender dragon is?
Guys.
Guys, who knows?
If you know where the ender dragon is...
Uh...
Alright, come over here.
Come over here, guys.
Alright, everybody come here.
Come here.
If you know where the ender dragon is...
I require...
Build a...
Build a PP tower right now so I know who to follow.
Uh...
If you are one of the...
One of the...
I know where the ender dragon is.
I need a PP tower so I know which one knows.
Give me a PP tower.
So I know you guys...
You know where the ender dragon is.
Somebody must have figured it out by now.
Did anybody figured it out?
Are none of the speedrunners in this...
In this area?
Are they in the new world?
Oh, the speedrunners are all in the new world.
Goddamn.
Goddamn it, we sent the wrong...
Oh my god.
Did we send the wrong...
...dragoons?
No one knows.
Alright.
Does anybody know where the fucking ender...
Is there no PP tower anywhere?
I'm stuck with the old world.
Dragoons!
Is there no dragoon with a PP tower that knows where the ender dragon is?
Oh wait.
Okay, wait.
Oh, this one!
These guys!
Alright, who do we trust?
We have two dragoons.
Okay, we have this one.
What's his name?
What's your name, sir?
We have an egg goon?
What's his name?
What's your name, sir?
Alright.
L for demon.
And then we have...
We have Tommy.
Alright, it's Tommy versus L.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna have a poll.
His poll...
His PP is bigger.
Alright, actually...
Whoever has the biggest PP tower will lead us to the ender dragon.
Whoever makes the biggest PP tower gets to lead us to the ender dragon.
And then Tommy has iron so I trust him.
Well, you better hurry.
Only the biggest PP tower can lead the... Okay, he took made it.
Is that really the biggest you have?
Is that really it?
Okay, well, we definitely know who's the winner here.
This guy stopped.
He stopped building.
Hahaha!
Wow!
Alright.
Tom- Tommy's gonna win, I think.
Tommy's gonna win.
Alright, Tommy!
That's okay!
You can stop now, Tommy!
He can stop now.
Tommy, we will follow you to the ender dragon!
Somebody light the bottom on fire.
That'd be so funny.
Is anyone at flint?
It's okay, Tommy lived!
He lived!
Tommy!
Wait, where did Tommy go?
He lived, guys!
Tommy actually lived!
Alright, Tommy!
Where did Tommy go?
Where did he go?
Tommy, lead us!
To the Ender Dragon, wherever you are!
Yeah, he lived!
I saw him!
The other guy died.
But I saw Tommy live.
Alright.
Is that Tommy?
Is Tommy trying to lead us right here?
Oh my god, Tommy!
Tommy, where are you?
There's so many people, Tommy!
Hahaha!
Wait, did he actually die?
Oh shit!
Wait, who's gonna lead us?
Oh, well, if Tommy died, we have a new leader now.
This guy!
Hahaha!
Whoever you are, you shall lead us!
To the Ender Dragon!
Hahaha!
Take us to the Ender Dragon!
Look!
Hahaha!
Alright!
Alright, he's dead too.
Okay.
Alright, you there!
Cosmic!
By...
Elimination!
Hahaha!
You get to be the leader, Cosmic!
Take us to the Ender Dragon!
Hahaha!
We're gonna follow you!
Cosmic, we're all ready!
Where is it?
Oh, Cosmic, he doesn't know!
He didn't even know!
We don't have actual leaders!
He doesn't even know!
He's like, wait, I was just joking!
Hahaha!
Cosmic was just joking!
What happened?
Oh, this guy!
Right here!
He's on his own pee-pee!
Alright!
You there!
You've done it!
You are now the leader!
To take us to the Ender Dragon!
All the other ones died!
So, congratulations!
Hahaha!
Congratulations!
You there!
All the other leaders!
Ender Dragon leaders died!
Oh!
Hahaha!
Cos I don't think we're gonna be led!
Guys, I think this position is cursed!
Guys, I think this position...
Other than Cosmic who was...
Who did not have the credentials...
Cosmic had no credentials to be a leader and was lying this entire time!
We don't have anybody to lead us, guys!
Everybody who has a pee-pee tower has so far, like, failed us!
Oh my gosh!
Whoops!
Hahaha!
You there!
You!
Do you know where the Ender Dragon is?
Come down!
You're the new leader now!
This time it'll work!
Come down!
Hahaha!
Don't build it any taller!
We've seen what happened!
Hahaha!
Come down!
We need you to lead us!
You must know where the Ender Dragon is!
Come down, but not too fast!
Hahaha!
Okay, this is...
Alright, you're the closest.
Okay, you're the closest to the ground.
Yamabro, alright, now you're the leader.
Yamabro, alright, you're the leader now.
Hahaha!
Alright, Yamabro!
Take us to the Ender!
Oh, it's right underneath us?
Guys, it's right underneath us!
Go!
If we all dig together, we can get to the...
We can get underneath!
Alright!
Guys, that's our leader!
That's our leader!
Keep digging!
We need to dig!
Dig down right now, everybody!
Dig down!
That's where the Ender Dragon is!
The Ender Dragon is right below!
Dig straight down!
Hahaha!
That's where it is!
I swear, I swear, if the New World Dragoons have made it to the Ender without us, I swear to God, guys, I swear to God, if the New World Dragoons have made it before us...
Hahaha!
Oh my God, there's water here.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, what do we do?
What do we do?
This is...
Guys, I don't think we planned this very well.
I don't think we planned this very well.
Hahaha!
Yammer Bro!
Where's the Ender?
Where is it?
Oh, it's me.
Okay, I'm fine.
I'm well...
Hahaha!
Where is it?
Oh my God!
The guy with lava!
Oh shit!
Are we going... What the fuck?
Okay, I guess we're going to the End.
Alright, we did it.
Now what?
Now what do we do?
Alright, guys.
You know...
Yammer Bro knows what they're doing!
Oh, sorry, the Nether!
We're going to the Nether!
Guys, Queen has like had to do a lot of stuff today, okay?
Hahaha!
The Queen has been through a lot.
Oh no!
Guys, I can't move up!
Wooo!
Somebody will take this!
Guys!
Guys, please!
Hahaha!
Somebody!
Oh, okay, nice, okay.
Alright, where do we go?
This way?
Alright.
Guys, we can't let the new world go!
The new world goons beat us to it, guys!
Guys!
We can't let the new world dragoons beat us!
Can't let America win!
Hahaha!
We can't let them win!
We're the old world dragoons!
Hahaha!
Where did Yamabro go?
Where did he go?
Over here!
Down here!
Okay, follow the pathway!
You'll be pussies!
Yeah!
Oh my god, that was half HP.
Okay, maybe a little pussy.
Alright, this way guys!
This way!
This way guys!
We can't let them beat the ender dragon!
Hahaha!
Wooo!
What happened?
There's so...
What did that?
Who fucking put a bed down?
Hahaha!
Who put a bed down?
What the fuck?
Wooo!
Oh!
Oh god!
Where are we?
Oh!
Did they do it?
What the fuck was it?
The new world dragoons?
Oh shit!
Did they do it?
Someone made it to the end?
Where is it?
We lost Yammer bro!
Where's Yammer?
Hahaha!
How the fuck?
How did they do it?
Guys!
How did we win?
Oh wait, they opened the portal.
Guys, they haven't done it yet guys!
They've only opened the portal.
Who are we following?
Hahaha!
We lost Yammer bro!
Guys, we lost the leader!
Guys!
Hahaha!
We've lost the leader!
Guys, where did he go?
Oh wait, I got TP.
You're right.
Haha!
Guys, TP to...
Yammer.
Goodbye guys.
Sorry, I messed it up.
TP Yammer bro.
I TP'd you here.
Now lead us.
Hahaha!
Oops, I re-fret.
Oh my god.
Now lead us.
Guys!
You know where... You do know where we're going, right?
You know where it is, right?
You actually... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Yammer bro!
We... Haha!
Guys, they're not gonna defeat the...
They're not gonna defeat the ender dragon without us!
Guys!
Okay?
They're not gonna do it!
Wait, what?
What?
Hahaha!
Where is... Where are they taking us?
It's okay, don't mind him!
We have an army!
I swear to god, if he's like...
All the other competent leaders die.
Hahaha!
All our other competent leaders have died.
All we have is Yammer bro.
Hahaha!
They built the PP Tower!
It was the shortest PP Tower ever built.
But they still built it!
Like...
It still happened!
Okay, I'm not standing near the edge of this.
Hahaha!
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I need a...
I fucked up.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Whoa!
Okay, that was close.
Does he... Does he know where he's going?
Look!
All the other leaders died!
This is all we have now!
We compromised!
Hahaha!
We had to compromise!
Okay?
All the other ones died!
Hahaha!
Alright.
I think he knows what he's doing.
Guys, I think he knows what...
Guys, he knows what he's doing, guys.
Like...
Look, he has a set up pathway.
So, like, surely, right?
Guys, I fell.
Where did he go?
What did... Oh, there he is!
Where is he taking us?
Guys, where is he taking...
Please!
The new world dragons!
We didn't get there before the new world dragons!
Hahaha!
We can't let the American goons win!
Please!
I called them uncivilized!
Hahaha!
They're gonna try and do a revolution if they find out!
If they beat the end before the rest of us, they're gonna...
Hahaha!
They're gonna try and succeed from Doki Land!
The...
The longest fight!
Hahaha!
Guys, it was unlucky that, like, the other...
the diamond dragoons in the old world died from the PP tower that they made.
Oh!
Shit!
Don't go up!
Don't!
Hahaha!
He
dug the lava!
He dug the...
Okay, it's time to TP again.
Hahaha!
Yeah...
What was it?
Doki...
Wait, how do you TP with me to the other person?
Like...
How do I...
No, that wasn't Yam bro!
How...
How do you do the TP to a person?
How do you...
TPA... Oh, TPA...
Yam bro...
Am I there?
Wait, where did...
Wait, did he die?
Oh!
Where is it?
Yeah!
Haha!
It's just you and...
three people!
Only three!
There's only three!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Wait, did I do TP?
Aww!
Guys, we did it!
Guys!
Guys, I...
Guys, I fucked up a little.
Hahaha!
I fucked up a little!
It's okay guys!
It's okay!
We're...
We're all here for the journey!
Hahaha!
Alright, where do we go?
Where did you take us?
How am I gonna go home?
How do I get home?
What do we do now?
This has been a terrible expedition!
Hahaha!
You fucked up!
I don't... Whoa!
I don't think you actually knew where it is!
I don't... I don't think...
Yeah bro!
I don't think you even knew where the end is!
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
Wait!
What did Yam bro do it?
This is where we came from?
Why are we...
Yam bro, why... Why are we back here?
Why?
Hahaha!
Alright, where's Yam bro?
Where is he?
Where's Yam bro?
Where is Yam bro?
Hahaha!
I need Yam bro here right now!
Alright!
Alright guys!
If anybody...
Yam bro!
Hahaha!
Alright!
Where did Yam bro go?
Yam bro!
Alright everybody!
Wait!
Yam bro wants to redeem himself!
Yam bro are you taking me to the end?
Hahaha!
Are you redeeming yourself?
Alright!
Yay!
Yam bro has a place to take us!
Alright!
Maybe it's not over yet for... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Maybe...
Maybe it's not over!
For Yam bro!
Haha!
Hahaha!
He has something!
He's cooking right now!
Hahaha!
He's cooking!
No!
He has somewhere to bring me, right?
Right Yam bro?
You're taking me somewhere!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
We're gonna take me!
No!
He's walking back!
We're back in Germany now!
And now we left Germany.
Okay!
We're gonna let him cook!
He clearly has...
He has an idea!
He has... He has...
He has an idea right now!
What is your idea?
You're making chicken!
Hahaha!
Yam bro!
I'm fucking... I don't know man!
Hahaha!
Yam bro I don't know anymore!
I don't know if you're actually cooking!
Hahaha!
He made it!
He made chicken!
Okay!
He's made...
He's made chicken!
Alright!
I believe in Yam bro!
Guys!
I still have faith!
He's got... He knows what he's doing!
Guys!
You guys are doubting him!
But he knows what he's doing!
You guys...
Guys!
He clearly knows what he's doing guys!
He might have taken us in the circle!
Like...
During... During the Nether!
But it's okay!
I fully believe in him!
He has a goal!
Alright!
Oh my god!
He remembered not to do that!
He clearly has a goal somewhere!
He has... Somewhere!
Right?
Hahaha!
Now where?
Where is it Yam bro?
Where are you headed?
The adventures of Yam bro!
The new world!
Always the new world!
You guys haven't killed the...
There's no way you guys killed the ender dragon yet!
Hahaha!
Old world!
Don't you disappoint me old world!
The new world!
You have to wait!
The new world has to wait!
For us!
Hahaha!
Where the fuck are you going?
Why do you need a tree?
Where...
Hahaha!
What are you crafting?
What are you...
Hahaha!
Guys I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I didn't trust this plan less and less.
Wait!
Yam bro has a bone?
Okay.
Alright.
Yam bro.
Row us.
To the end.
Hahaha!
It's been like...
Bro the new world has been at the end for like 20 years now!
Hahaha!
I've just been tagging along!
Row us to the new world!
Hahaha!
How you can't say it was my fault?
I literally...
I literally was like...
Alright guys.
Who knows where the end is?
Whoever has the biggest PP tower gets to take us to the new world.
Not new world.
Gets to take us to the end and beat the new worlders.
But then...
Everybody died.
He was literally like the last person left alive.
I could not do anything else.
He was literally the last one.
Alright where is it?
I don't know.
I didn't decide to follow him!
We had no other choice left!
All our other picks died!
From mysterious circumstances!
They all died mysteriously!
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Somebody lives here?
Who the fuck lives here?
Hahaha!
Let him cook.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are we like...
No we are... Are we in Europe?
Guys the UK is not in Europe anymore because of...
Because...
Because of Brexit.
Hahaha!
We are back in Europe guys!
The Fargoons.
Alright.
Does he know?
Dude!
Somebody's dog is here!
They brought their dogs!
Hahaha!
Is this like...
Wait is this it?
Oh shit!
Wait what the fuck?
Why did you...
Why did you take us to the...
Wait why did you take us here?
Bro!
Why did you take us to a fucking...
Okay we are like...
Hahaha!
We are just...
We are literally just...
What do you want me to have?
Literally on this mad simoncraft chair.
Why did you take us to the jungle temple?
Wait...
What the...
I am... I don't know guys.
I'm trusting this process less and less right now.
Hahaha!
I don't...
I don't know.
He stopped for a temple.
I don't think he actually knows.
I don't...
Guys I'm starting to think he doesn't know guys.
I don't know.
I'm starting to think he doesn't actually know where it is.
I don't...
What's that for?
What's...
Yeah bro what?
What's that for?
It's over yeah bro.
Alright new leader time.
Build the biggest...
Longest peepee tower.
It's over for yeah bro.
His journey ends here.
His journey...
Hahaha!
I need a new leader.
This...
The new leader give me a peepee tower you actually know.
Hahaha!
Give me a peepee tower if you actually know where the end is.
Alright.
You there.
What's your name?
Wifi.
Alright wifi take us to the fucking end.
Hahaha!
Oh shit JK.
No you sir over here.
This guy.
You.
You over there.
You're the new leader.
Take us to the end.
The new world will like to declare.
It's not over yet.
We haven't made it.
Alright this guy.
Get down here.
The new world.
We gotta beat the new world.
Oh he lives.
Alright.
Corval.
Show us.
Show us where it is.
If you don't know where...
If you fuck us over.
Hahaha!
The tide that filled the air.
Bro!
Yeah bro was fucking baiting us this entire time.
Oh my god!
He was actually baiting us.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Holy shit.
He was actually baiting us.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna fucking mooch off your boat sir.
Project.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Follow him.
Hahaha!
You let that new...
I can't believe it.
He was a new world spy.
I'm calling it now.
He was a fucking new world spy.
Hehehehehe.
Hahaha.
He did it for the new world.
Now it...
The sleeper agent.
Follow that man over there.
Follow Corso.
He's gonna do something.
They told you since the nether.
Hahaha.
I can't believe it.
Follow him!
He knows where the end is.
If we doesn't...
We know what we do to spies.
Hehehehehe.
Hahaha.
I should have killed him when we came back from the nether.
I...
But you all told me to give him a chance.
Hahaha.
You all said...
You don't believe in him.
He's not fucking you over.
Hahaha.
Believe in him.
I fucking knew it.
I knew he was a spy.
Hahaha.
Follow him.
He knows where it is.
He knows...
He must know where it is.
I believe in him.
I believe in our new leader.
Hahaha.
Don't worry.
Guys, we can't end stream until we defeat the Ender Dragon.
Guys, we can't!
You guys haven't won yet!
You guys haven't beat the Ender Dragon yet!
You guys haven't done it yet.
No, we're doing this legit!
We're doing this legit!
He knows where it is!
He knows!
Corvo knows!
Corvo, what do you see?
What do you see, Corvo?
Do you feel the stronghold?
Do you feel it?
What does he feel?
Does he also feel the air?
Wait, I lost... Where did Corvo go?
Why are we killing cows?
Wait, where did Corvo go?
Where did the fucking...
Where did the Monokuma go?
Guys!
Guys...
What's that?
No, I didn't know what you were talking about.
That was my BGM, guys.
Guys, we don't know exactly what that sound could be.
Guys, we don't know!
Guys, it's not over yet!
Guys, we don't know what that sound was.
Okay, that's not Corvo.
Alright, we... That's okay, that's not him.
Guys, we don't know who that was!
That could be anything!
We don't know if it's the new Wargoon.
They have to send a pigeon letter.
Guys, we don't know yet, guys.
We don't know yet.
They haven't had their tea party moment yet.
We don't know.
That could have been anybody.
Guys, I lost... I lost the guy.
I lost him.
It's too late.
I lost... Oh, sleeping through this night.
Oh, wait.
The moment of stay time.
We'll see.
Yeah, that could have been the Wither.
We don't know yet.
Yeah, that could have been anything.
We don't know exactly what that sound was.
Alright, where is it?
Corvo, where is it?
Where is... I don't know what you're looking at, but I hope you actually know what you're doing.
Okay, bad man.
It's not fair!
We had a secret agent!
We literally had a plant!
That fucked us over!
We should have...
We should have... Our competent leaders all died under mysterious circumstances.
That could have been anything.
That could have been a bird!
You know the birds can, like, repeat stuff?
The birds repeat mods?
No way!
You don't know that!
New World Graven member already killed three Ender Dragons.
We don't know that!
There's no proof!
They don't even have stream proof!
There's no proof that the New World goons did it!
Guys, I lost our leader.
Where did our leader go?
Guys, where did he go?
Guys, where did Corvo go?
Are we following the right people?
Like... guys...
Guys, I think we...
We lost the leader.
Guys, we lost the leader.
Guys, where did he go?
Guys, where...
Where did he go, guys?
I lost him!
Where did the leader...
Guys, where did he go?
Where did the bear go?
Oh no...
Guys, I don't see him.
Guys, I don't see the bear anymore.
I don't...
I don't see him, guys.
Guys, we lost...
Oh no...
Guys, we lost the leader.
Guys...
Where...
Are we gonna find...
Guys, I have a feeling none of you guys actually know where he is.
Guys, I have a feeling none of you guys actually know where...
Where Corvo is.
Guys, how do we teleport?
Guys, how do we teleport but not TP all?
Where's Corvo?
Where is he?
That's not Corvo, they're just building new...
They're just building new towers.
I'm not blind!
I don't see him!
Oh, is he over there?
Did you guys know?
Wait, he knows!
He knows!
He actually knows!
Wait, new leader.
Guys.
Where did the leader go?
Guys, where did the leader go?
Where did the new leader go?
He took us to water and I lost him!
No, I'm gonna die!
Oh.
Oh god.
Guys.
Guys, where's the new leader?
Guys, we lost him!
He took us to the water and he disappeared!
Oh wait, no, there he is!
There he is!
New leader!
He knows!
Do you actually know?
Are you fucking with us too?
Do you ask your new leader?
Do you know?
Does he know?
Guys, we need to kill the ender dragon, please.
Alright.
The only leader... Alright.
Show me the ender pearl!
If you wanna be a leader, you have to have the ender pearl on you.
Right now.
I need to see a pearl.
I need to see... I need to see the pearl.
Whoever has the pearl, can be the leader.
Whoever has the pearl gets to be the leader.
Do none of you have pearls?
Do you...
Oh, sorry.
The ender eye.
Do none of you...
The eye of ender...
Do none...
That is not the eye of...
None of you have eye of ender.
Do none of you...
Guys, I don't think any of...
Okay.
I have... I think none of them actually knew.
I don't think anybody... none of them actually knew.
Okay.
I...
Who could have known?
The pee-pee towers.
Alright.
I left them stranded in the middle of nowhere.
That's their new home now.
That's... that's... that's their new home.
I picked the wrong team.
That's... that's their new home now.
And...
That's... that's... that's where they're gonna live.
Alright!
Who has the Eye of Ender?
Do any dragoons have...
the Eye of Ender?
Anybody here?
You guys are the people I left stranded!
How did you guys get back here?
I left you guys stranded!
Alright.
Okay.
It's teleport...
How do I do this?
TP...
Alright.
Who...
What, Orca?
Alright.
We did it, guys.
Guys.
We did it.
Summon the Ender Dragon.
What the fuck?
Who died?
Summon the Ender Dragon!
The queen is here now!
The queen is here!
I demand the new world!
The queen is here to get the taxes!
We twit...
No!
The revolution has started!
Oh!
Oh my god.
They tried to tea party me.
Those new world goons.
They're crazy.
They're savages.
They're fucking savages over there.
Those new world goons.
Oh my god.
This is why we left them.
Guys, this is why we left them on that island.
This is exactly why.
Not you guys.
Old world goons.
My old world goons.
Don't worry.
We won't let the new world goons do this to us.
Guys.
My old world goons.
We will prosper.
I might not command the new world anymore.
But we are not savages.
Like them.
We're not.
We are the old world for a reason.
We have our other territories.
We have our other territories, guys.
The new world is not the only...
The new world is not the only place that we have colonized.
We have other places.
So do not worry.
I believe in us.
We have the rest of Europe.
Guys.
The goddamn old world.
Thinking they can fight back to their queen.
How dare they.
How fucking dare they.
Guys, I should not...
The PP Tower was not a good form of government.
Like, I have learned that now.
We're never establishing...
We have Germany.
Exactly.
We literally have Germany and Lithuania.
Lina, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
It's okay.
The new world is still under my rule.
New world.
If you hear me now, new world.
I'm broadcasting my message to across the ocean.
The new world, if you hear me, just so you know, I still...
I have owner power.
I can destroy everything you love, new world.
I...
I can bring Flint over to the new world.
So don't piss me off.
I still have perms over the new world.
Let's see, I need eat...
All right.
A golden.
It'll be fine if I eat a golden.
A golden, a glistening melon.
It'll be fine.
It'll be fine, guys.
I want to see how my dock is going.
My old world dock.
All right, let's see.
Throw the taxes into the ocean.
They can't do that.
Like I said, I have old world power.
We're back in Doki Land.
Alright, how's the dock going?
Port attempt made.
Subscribe- What the fuck?
Who the f- can you advertise?
What?
Who took the taxes?
Somebody took the taxes!
Who
yoinked my taxes?
This has to be the New World's doing.
There's no way.
This has to- Those fucking savages.
I can't believe it!
They teapot-ed me!
They actually teapot-ed me in the port!
They dumped it to the harbor!
Those f- Oh my god.
Guys.
I know I said like all dragoons are created equally.
Guys, I'm gonna make a speech.
I know I said all dragoons are created equally.
I need to be in Doki Land.
But like...
Those New World goons.
There's a reason why we banished them all the way back there.
I knew not doing public housing in the New World was a good idea.
Now they'll ne- If they try and ask for me to give them like...
To give them government funding.
I will never give them government funding.
You old world goons.
You guys.
You guys are special.
Those New World goons.
I know I said all dragoons are created equally.
But the New World goons.
They are not as equal.
Are we really gonna let them?
Dump our taxes into the ocean?
Some goons are more equal than others.
Oh my god.
That's fun though.
Legoland.
What the fuck?
Where's Legoland?
Is this Legoland?
There's savages.
Savages.
Barely even human.
Oh my god.
They try to fight back to your queen.
How could they?
Oh my god.
Hey guys.
What the fuck?
How did you guys get here?
Why the fuck did you guys jump on top?
Wait.
How did you guys do that?
What?
Oh.
I thought you can't build there.
Alright guys.
I also wanna slash this.
I'm gonna call it here.
It's been fun.
I definitely had...
We had no BGM after...
After what happened...
Um...
After what happened today...
I'll put the BGM back on.
But after what happened...
With being led in the wild goose chase...
I have got rid of the BGM.
Because that's what we deserve.
But...
I had a lot of fun with all you guys today.
I cannot wait to play more on the...
Dragoon server in the future.
Um...
And also improve the server for all of you guys.
I can't wait to improve the server.
If you guys have like...
Any notes you guys wanna do...
Like how...
Like stuff to do...
Improve the server...
Like any ideas you wanna add...
We're gonna implement a better chat system...
So people can chat with others...
Within groups...
Within factions...
Um...
But you have any ideas or anything...
Regarding like...
How to improve this Dragoon server...
Feel free to...
Comment on the VOD itself...
And then we'll look through the VOD.
Um...
And then obviously I will host like events...
I will redecorate some parts here...
I will have more quality of life changes...
But I definitely had...
Oh my god...
I had a lot of fun.
Hahahaha...
I had so much fun guys...
Um...
I'm really happy that...
We finally have our server now...
Um...
Why is there a boat here?
I'm really happy that we finally...
Got our server up and going...
And I'm so excited to see what you guys are gonna build...
Uh...
But yes!
Everybody...
I'm gonna call it here guys...
I'm gonna call it here...
Um...
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated...
Posture check...
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing...
And if you...
Stay up for me...
Hit the bed...
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!